[Music]
so I'm up I'm wearing absolutely no
makeup right now and just makes you fool
Kylie Jenner and Dad Caitlyn have some
fun with filters yeah what are they what
is an Instagram filter because they I
saw Oh Kylie's using Instagram filters
what the hell is that Instagram just
launched some Kylie cosmetics themed
two-faced filters that essentially let
users test out
Kylie's range of products I'm wearing
cozy right now I'm the face to my brand
and I take responsibility for everything
that happens
Kylie's cosmetic empire is set to make
her the youngest self-made up
billionaire ever
according to Forbes now this cover cut
the soon-to-be 21 year old some flack
but her famous fam is sticking up for
her she spent her money on a venture
that could have gone south or north and
it did really well so I think that takes
away from the fact that there was hard
work put into something I think that I
think that you that doesn't just happen
if you're if you're not doing something
about it you're just sitting at home
being lazy I don't think that could
happen
yeah I think it says something about
just working
[Music]